madame monsieur bonsoir les rues de
tonnes cette petite ville de haute
savoie était noire de monde cet après
midi pour fêter le retour au pays du
héros de tout un peuple
aimé jacquet le bien nommé aura été
acclamé comme personnes regardaient plus
tôt françois dom jean piat liman cela
fait 38 ans que le sélectionneur de
l'équipe championne du monde vient en
vacances ici au coeur des aravis mais il
possède un chalet qu'il a appelé le
girondin
tone a toujours cru en une victoire
française la preuve
aimé jacquet et citoyen d'honneur de la
petite ville depuis déjà deux ans à will
survive la chanson fétiche des bleus où
la marseillaise entonnée spontanément
par une foule venue de toute la vallée
et à laquelle ces thèmes et les
touristes français ou étrangers et mais
a eu droit ici aussi à son triomphe
je dirais que physiquement je suis pas
une grande grande forme mais c'est
normal il ya un petit peu la chute d'une
pression il ya aussi une vie qui a été
terrible pendant longtemps maintenant
j'essaye de retrouver les gestes
quotidiens qui retrouvait sur mes amis
je dirais aussi que c'est plus facile
le manager 22 joueurs des constate de
france que d'être devant vous ce soir
monsieur jacquet est reparti dans son
chalet il décompresse eux soufflé
retrouve une vie normale
aujourd'hui il a fait une randonnée de
quatre heures sous le soleil
oui